who was the best host of the weekend
updates you know Dan Aykroyd which did
that Bill Murray you know uh Norm
Macdonald I'm trying to think Chevy
Chase he was Chevy Chase was the
original Weekend Update guys Dennis
Miller Dennis Miller unbelievable who
was the best well because the era I was
on we only remember the best shows and
the best sketches but I remember a lot
of shows like by the time we got to
update we sucked it was like the
audience was like what is this why did
we go it's late can we can we get it can
we leave now no you really should stay
it's a live television show and then
Dennis who is I've I did a long car ride
with Dennis once and he just sat in the
back and wrote like a hundred great
jokes
wow uh just just out of it so Dennis for
me who's a little bit unheralded in a
way because
whatever the political theater is of the
day
um I I'll have to go with him